[Music]  singer Tom Petty has died Tom Petty went  into cardiac arrest on Sunday night this  according to TMZ the singer was rushed  to the hospital after being found  unconscious of course the 66 year old is  known for his iconic songs like I won't  back down and free fallin and as the  lead singer of Tom Petty and the  Heartbreakers their hits include  American girl  don't do me like that and learn into fly  [Music]  Petie had just wrapped a series of shows  at the Hollywood Bowl in Los Angeles  [Music]  the band had been on tour celebrating  its 40th anniversary the tour began in  April a cert goer from one of those  Hollywood shows tells ET petit quote  seemed upbeat energetic and his  performance was great  he bantered with the audience and  appeared to be healthy and happy  [Applause]